Now that you know a little about how
your app will be visually organized, and
some of the common design
patterns you might use,
let's talk about how you can
customize its look and feel.
Android uses themes and
styles to create reusable sets of
attributes that can be applied
to your UI to customize it.
It's similar to CSS on the web.
A style the appearance
of a single UI element.
You might change the style of
an element for branding reasons,
such as the color or the font.
Or for
practical reasons such as legibility.
A theme uses the same syntax as a style,
but applied as a collection of
styles to an element, an activity,
or even your whole application.
Now styles always operate
on a single element.
Whereas themes cascade to its children.
For example, if you wanted to turn all
of the buttons in your application
pink to match your branding,
then you can create a style to do that.
And then apply it to
the whole application theme.
Next up James will show you
how to apply this lesson.